- Good morning Believe Nation.
Today's message is follow your heart.
Over to you, Shaquille O'Neal.
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Espresso keep me going
- What is it about investment
and entrepreneurship
that sort of has bitten you?
- I never look at it as
investments, believe it or not.
I just look at it as partnerships,
help changing the world,
and just being part of
something that's inspiring.
My business people, all the time,
whenever they talk about money,
you can ask them, I'm like, ah,
I don't want to hear it.
But if they bring an idea to me
that I think is going
to go to the next level,
most of the time if I follow my heart,
then everything else will fall into place.
I've never ever done a deal,
eh, we've got this suit company,
we throw some pinstripes in the suit,
you give me 100,000, we
sell 20 of them, we make.
I've never did a deal where
it was always based on money.
I always did my business
deals based on how I felt
it was going to go in the future,
how I felt it was going to
help and inspire somebody.
- If you are starting a business
just trying to make money,
you're going to lose.
This is how so many
people go out of business.
They read the magazine of
the 100 hottest startups
to start this year, and
they try them and they fail.
You lose.
I don't know how many times
you need to hear this message.
I don't know how many
times we have profiled
different successful people.
I think this channel,
we've profiled more successful people
than maybe anybody else,
maybe any other YouTube channel,
maybe any other publication, period.
Maybe.
If we're not there, we're in the top.
From athletes to musicians to
entrepreneurs to politicians
to inventors to artists
all over the world,
people from different
countries, different cultures,
different races, different genders,
and the single most consistent thing
that everybody says is you
have to follow your heart.
You have to have passion for
the work that you're doing.
I don't know how many
times you need to hear it.
I don't know that,
we're making another video on it.
A lot of you guys are going to get it.
A lot of you guys still won't get it.
Hopefully by hearing it from
Shaquille O'Neal this time
and different entrepreneurs,
at some point it's going to sink in.
If the only reason that
you're doing something
is just for the money,
you will always live paycheck to paycheck
'cause there's nothing
deeper driving you forward.
As soon as you get enough
money to pay your bills,
you're going to ease up the throttle
and you won't have any success,
where if you're driven by something
more than just making money
and making money is important.
Listen, we're running a business.
You got to make money.
Money provides for a
lot of amazing things.
It's not that money is evil.
There just has to be
something above money,
something driving you.
Look at whoever you look up to most.
Whoever has the most
success in your industry,
they wanted to change the
way something was done.
They had this thing inside them
that they had to get out,
and they made a lot of money
in the process of doing it.
But money was never the number one goal.
It never is.
And so, I hope that by
hearing the message again,
for some of you, it's going to sink in,
and this is going to be the
time that you actually decide
to do the thing that
you're passionate about
because I don't want you wasting time.
I don't want you just
wanting to be an entrepreneur
'cause you want the
entrepreneur lifestyle.
I want you to do something important.
And it's only going to
come by leaning in heavily
on the thing that you are
most passionate about.
So, the question of the day today is
I'm curious, who is the
most successful person
that you look up to
that really exemplifies
that characteristic of
just loving what they do
and put in the hustle,
hard work, and effort?
Who is that person for you?
Super curious to find out.
Leave it down in the comments below.
I also want to give a quick
shout out to Michael Brown.
Michael, thank you so
much for picking up a copy
of my book, Your One Word.
It really means a lot to me, man,
and I hope you're enjoying the read.
Thank you guys again for watching.
I hope you have an amazing day.
I believe in you
and hope you continue
to believe in yourself.
And I'll see you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of Entspresso.
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Espresso keep me going
- The last Rocky movie before
Creed, the final scene,
was it your way of saying
goodbye to the character,
goodbye to that?
- Yeah, goodbye to everything,
goodbye to the best chapters of my life,
at least professional life.
It really was.
Then, along comes this
young guy to Oakland
and I'm going, what?
- Ryan Coogler.
- [Robin] When director Ryan Coogler
first met with Stallone,
he was untested as a feature filmmaker,
but he had an intensely personal idea
for reviving the Rocky franchise.
Coogler's father had fallen
gravely ill a few years earlier.
With Ryan by his side,
there was only one thing the
elder Coogler wanted to watch.
- The father is a very
soulful powerful man,
and now, he's being reduced
to a shell of his former self.
But oddly, he watches Rocky
again and again and again.
This son, who loves his father,
sitting right beside him,
and he's watching his father
disintegrate before his very eyes,
the traumatic impact was so
imprinted on this young man
that he never got over it.
So, he comes to me and he goes,
"Hey, look at this great idea.
"I'm going to revive Rocky."
I go, "How?"
And when he told me his story,
I said, "This is insane, wrong."
You're a young kid.
You haven't done anything yet,
but I appreciate the thought.
He goes, "Okay, see you around."
And he goes out and he does a masterpiece,
Fruitvale Station, wins
the Cannes Film Festival.
Every studio wants him.
What's he want to do?
Creed.
I went, now, either this guy here is just
trying my patience or he reminds
me of a guy I used to know.
- I was going to say,
that was you 40 years ago.
- Yeah, it was.
Absolutely.
Then, I realized this
is not a movie for him.
It's for his father.
This is all about a love
letter to his father.
- Now, if you really dug down deep
and ask a real Rocky fan
why he likes the movies,
it's usually because they watched them
with someone that they loved.
What's so great about them
is they're so personal to people.
People just associate
them with their family.
- [Narrator] This young, dedicated artist
can't help but reflect on
those who once doubted him.
- They never said I
wasn't talented enough.
They'll say something like,
"The industry is shady.
"You don't need to be doing this."
I respect their opinions,
but at the end of the day,
I had to follow my heart
and that's what I wanted to do.
It was a passion.
I couldn't shake it.
And I'd be hurt now if
I didn't stick with it
'cause it'd always be in my head.
- And Paul, when you first
signed up for the first one,
which was back in '99, 2000,
did you think you'd be
sitting here in 2013,
talking about number six?
- No, not a chance.
No screenplay, nothing, when I signed on.
It was just an idea.
And it was funny because
I wanted to do it,
working with my friends
'cause I'd already worked
with these people before.
And they're like, "You can't do it."
My representatives were
telling me, "You can't do it."
There's no script.
There's nothing.
- That's really funny.
- You didn't listen to their advice?
- You were right.
- I got lucky.
But it was just following
your heart kind of thing,
and it wasn't even about down the road.
It was about living in
the moment and got lucky.